welcome back to CBS mornings we are now
more than a month since that massive
train derailment and toxic chemical
spill in East Palestine Ohio we're going
to take you back to East Palestine today
to learn how residents lives have
changed since that disaster Roxanna
siberi has been there from the beginning
and she's speaking with people in the
community at the very same moment as the
Norfolk Southern CEO gets ready to
testify on Capitol Hill today Roxanna I
imagine a lot of residents are going to
be following that closely good morning
Good morning Tony they will be many
people here tell me they love this night
tight-knit Community but they worry
they'll never get their old lives back
when they didn't have to think about
whether the water air and soil would
make them sick they say since the train
toppled here off these tracks over a
month ago they've been living in fear
while fighting for normalcy
this is exactly how we left the house
kind of hard to look at Valentine's Day
decorations drawings on the fridge
children's toys in the bedroom Frozen in
time yeah yeah pretty much feels like a
crime scene being in here for Sarah
Monteleone and her family the life they
knew in East Palestine came to a
standstill just before 9 pm on February
3rd this is where both of my kids were
having a sleepover the night that it
happened that night a train carrying
hazardous materials burst into flames
just two blocks away what's the hardest
part about this
um
we had a lot of Firsts in this house
we raised our family here we just had to
go and that's like this this was this
chapter just slammed shut for us and for
many others around 5 000 people live
here in East Palestine but when the
train went off these tracks spewing
toxic chemicals many residents fled Town
leaving some of these homes empty now
many aren't sure if it'll ever be safe
enough to return
[Music]
some nights it smells burns your eyes
just 100 feet from the tracks Eric
Whiting says his house has lost at least
half its value and he doesn't have the
means to move away I didn't expect it to
pollute the town with all the chemicals
and toxins but here we are
officials say soil tests don't show
harmful levels of toxins
and claim the municipal water is safe
that's our water but Whiting drinks only
bottled water so in the ideal World
you'd want Norfolk Southern to buy you
out I would love to be bought out and I
would love to walk away
now as rail operator Norfolk Southern
digs up the tracks to remove
contaminated soil it's offering
residents like Whiting debit cards his
families are for three thousand dollars
to evacuate for the next few weeks it
doesn't make me whole that just keeps my
family safer
for a while for a while
there are signs the town is trying to
feel whole at the packed sprinkles Diner
the True Value hardware shop and by the
high school
but Monteleone who's now staying two
miles from home says she plans to move
much farther away possibly forever you
feel it's not safe here either right we
might feel normal for two days and the
next day our eyes are burning and our
throat hurts again how can anyone
confidently raise their babies here
I can't take my child to the car without
her eyes watering that's not normal
that's not okay
Sarah told me who would her new normal
is brushing teeth with bottled water she
says she just wants answers and
hopefully she gets some today at the
Senate hearing with Norfolk Southern's
CEO Alan Shaw a written copy of his
testimony obtained by CBS News
reiterates the company's commitment to
pay for the town's cleanup Vlad
all right let's see if they follow
through Roxanna thank you very much